In recent years, the words diversity, equity, and inclusion have become political flashpoints. In 2023, legislators in 22 states introduced bills to restrict DEI efforts, including prohibiting state colleges from having DEI offices or staff, and banning mandatory diversity training. Seven of those bills have become law. Against this contentious backdrop, the science and evidence on why diversity matters are often ignored. Today, we're going to talk about that research and the role that psychologists play in DEI work. So what does diversity, equity, and inclusion mean?
近年来，“多元、公平和包容”（DEI）这些词汇已成为政治上的引爆点。2023年，22个州的立法者提出了限制DEI工作的法案，包括禁止公立大学设立DEI办公室或配备相关人员，以及禁止强制性的多元化培训。其中七项法案已成为法律。在这种充满争议的背景下，关于为何多元化至关重要的科学依据和证据往往被忽视。今天，我们将讨论这些研究，以及心理学家在DEI工作中扮演的角色。那么，多元、公平和包容究竟意味着什么？
How has our understanding of racial and ethnic identity changed over the years? And how has the research informed diversity, equity, and inclusion efforts? What does the research say about why we should all care about diversity in our schools, workplaces, and other institutions? And what can psychological science add to discussions about diversity? University. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Robert Sellers, the Charles D. Moody collegiate professor of psychology
多年来，我们对种族和民族认同的理解发生了怎样的变化？这些研究又是如何为多元、公平和包容工作提供参考的？研究表明，为什么我们都应该关注学校、工作场所和其他机构中的多元化？心理科学又能为关于多元化的讨论增添什么？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是罗伯特·塞勒斯博士，他是密歇根大学查尔斯·D·穆迪心理学与教育学讲席教授。
and education at the University of Michigan. He has been a professor at Michigan since 1997. From 2016 to 2021, he also served as the university's vice provost for equity and inclusion and chief diversity officer. Dr. Sellar's research has focused on ethnic and racial identity and the role of race in the psychological lives of African Americans. He has studied the significance and meaning that African Americans place on race in defining themselves, the ways in which parents transmit messages about race to their children, and the ways in which black people cope with racial discrimination. Dr. Sellers has won numerous awards for his work, including the 2022 American Psychological Foundation Gold Medal Award for Impact in Psychology
他自1997年起就在密歇根大学担任教授。2016年至2021年，他还担任了该校负责公平与包容的副教务长及首席多元化官。塞勒斯博士的研究重点是民族和种族认同，以及种族在非裔美国人心理生活中的作用。他研究了非裔美国人在自我定义中赋予种族的意义和重要性，父母向子女传递种族信息的方式，以及黑人应对种族歧视的方式。塞勒斯博士因其工作赢得了众多奖项，包括2022年美国心理学基金会心理学影响力金奖，
and the 2023 Association for Psychological Sciences, James L. Jackson, Lifetime Achievement Award for Transformative Scholarship. Dr. Sellers, thank you for joining me. It's a pleasure, Kim. I'm looking forward to our conversation. Now, you gave a presentation at APA's convention in the summer of 2023 called Why Psychologists should care about racial and ethnic diversity. Since many of the listeners to this podcast are not psychologists and didn't attend the convention, let's start with the really big question. Why should all of us care about diversity? Why is it important that we prioritize diversity
以及2023年心理科学协会詹姆斯·L·杰克逊变革性学术终身成就奖。塞勒斯博士，感谢您接受我的采访。很高兴见到你，金。我很期待我们的谈话。您在2023年夏季的美国心理学会年会上做过一场题为“为什么心理学家应该关注种族和民族多元化”的演讲。由于本播客的许多听众并非心理学家，也没有参加过年会，让我们从一个非常宏大的问题开始：为什么我们所有人都应该关注多元化？为什么优先考虑多元化在我们的学校、工作场所和其他机构中如此重要？
in our schools, workplaces, and other institutions? Well, oftentimes diversity is thought of in terms of how do we include individuals and groups that have historically not been included in whether it's our sciences, in the workplace, in education, whatever environment. The notion of diversity, equity, and inclusion has always sort of focused on writing the wrong, addressing the needs of those who traditionally not been included. And while that is absolutely important and I strongly support those efforts and think those, that motivation is important, is also an even larger argument and a larger issue that's at play. That by excluding those experiences of those groups and both through the science, our theories, our applications, we're not only damaging their life chances, but we're also diminishing the science itself and damaging the
嗯，通常人们认为多元化是指我们如何包容那些在历史上未被纳入科学、工作场所、教育或任何环境中的个人和群体。多元、公平和包容的概念一直侧重于纠正错误，满足那些传统上未被包容的人群的需求。虽然这绝对重要，我也强烈支持这些努力，并认为这种动机很重要，但还有一个更大的论点和更大的问题在起作用。那就是，通过在科学、理论和应用中排除这些群体的经验，我们不仅损害了他们的生活机会，也削弱了科学本身，并损害了
applicability of treatments as well as drugs and other things that we look forward to enhance society's challenges with regards to mental health and other psychological outcomes. The fact of the matter is that we as individuals bring to the table different experiences, different understandings, and that those different understandings are key to the growth of our ability to actually solve big and important problems. And so if we are limited in terms of those experiences and limited in terms of those insights, then our efforts to solve those big problems are in and of themselves limited. So we will not have everything at the table.
治疗方法、药物以及我们期待用来改善社会在心理健康和其他心理结果方面挑战的其他事物的适用性。事实是，我们作为个人带来了不同的经验和不同的理解，而这些不同的理解对于我们真正解决重大且重要问题的能力增长至关重要。因此，如果我们受限于这些经验和见解，那么我们解决这些重大问题的努力本身也会受到限制。所以，我们无法在讨论桌上汇集所有的观点。
And that's one of the things that we know in psychology is that diversity of perspective is really key to developing innovative ideas, to create a more effective ideas, and ultimately to solving big problems. Diversity, equity, and inclusion are often spoken of as a unit. The three words are grouped together, but I'd like to break them down. Can you talk about what each word means and why it's important to work toward all three? So the best way for me to do that is to note that, so when I think of diversity, I'm thinking of trying to capture the totality of the experience.
这是我们在心理学中已知的一点，即视角的多元化对于开发创新理念、创造更有效的想法，并最终解决重大问题至关重要。多元、公平和包容通常作为一个整体被提及。这三个词被归为一组，但我希望能把它们拆解开来。您能谈谈每个词的含义，以及为什么努力实现这三者都很重要吗？对我来说，最好的方式是指出，当我想到多元化时，我是在试图捕捉经验的整体性。
of whether you're talking about a student body, in the case of higher education or education in general, or a team in terms of in corporate America, the team working on the problem, the solution, we're talking about the totality of the human experience being captured. Too often, because of long-term historical, societal, injustices and inequities, certain experiences are privileged and other experiences are not, so much to the point that we sometimes think that there's a normative American experience
无论你是在谈论学生群体（以高等教育或一般教育为例），还是在谈论团队（以美国企业为例），即致力于解决问题和方案的团队，我们谈论的是人类经验的整体性被捕捉到。由于长期的历史和社会不公正与不平等，某些经验被赋予了特权，而其他经验则没有，以至于我们有时认为存在一种规范性的美国经验，
or a normative human experience as opposed to recognize that there's a great deal of diversity in those experiences. And so the first thing is trying to capture a more heterogeneous group of people, group of experiences, and bringing them into play in terms of everything that we're doing, particularly as it relates to solving important problems. But having those different experiences and those different perspectives isn't enough
或规范性的人类经验，而不是认识到这些经验中存在着巨大的多元性。因此，第一步是试图捕捉一个更多元化的群体和更多元化的经验，并将它们应用到我们所做的一切中，特别是与解决重要问题相关的事情上。但是，拥有这些不同的经验和不同的视角是不够的，
if you still have those inequities. And so would I think of inequities? of inequity, I think of the historical contemporary ways in which some people are allowed to participate in other people or not, or allowed to participate in certain ways that other people are not. And so breaking down those barriers are also extremely important. So just having diversity, but still having those barriers, doesn't provide a those benefits. And then inclusion is really the hardest part because that also means that we are changing and dealing with issues of power, that everybody's perspective is somehow valued and
如果你仍然存在那些不平等。那么，当我想到不平等时，我想到的是历史上和当代的一些方式，即某些人被允许参与，而另一些人则不被允许，或者被允许以某些方式参与，而其他人则不行。因此，打破这些障碍也极其重要。所以，仅仅拥有多元化，但仍然存在那些障碍，并不能带来那些好处。而包容性确实是最困难的部分，因为它也意味着我们正在改变和处理权力问题，即每个人的视角都以某种方式受到重视和
included, which means that's changing who determines what counts and what doesn't count. So an example that I often use is if I'm trying to solve a problem, would I rather have at the table six people who look just like me, who have exactly the same experiences I do, who know the same things that I do, who don't know the same things that I don't know in solving this problem, or would I rather have six people who are around the table with me with very different perspectives? different strengths, different weaknesses that we bring together to attack the problem. And in most cases, people would say, I'd rather have the former. I want that diversity of perspective. And that's great. But if you have that diversity of perspective, but yet three people in your group are not allowed to speak just by a function of who they are. maybe it's the color of the shirt that they're wearing or their gender or any number of things,
包容，这意味着要改变谁来决定什么算数，什么不算数。我经常使用的一个例子是：如果我试图解决一个问题，我是愿意桌上有六个看起来和我一模一样、拥有和我完全相同经验、知道和我一样多知识、不知道和我一样多知识的人来解决这个问题，还是愿意有六个和我围坐在桌旁、拥有非常不同视角的人？我们汇集不同的优势和劣势来攻克这个问题。在大多数情况下，人们会说，我更愿意选择后者。我想要那种视角的多元化。这很好。但如果你拥有了那种视角的多元化，但你的小组中有三个人仅仅因为他们的身份而不被允许发言，也许是因为他们穿的衬衫颜色、性别或任何其他原因，
but they're not allowed to participate just because of who they are. That doesn't help you. And if two other people may be allowed to participate, but just two minutes ago, they were questioned outside of the room about whether or not they belong based on their identity, they're not going to be able to contribute at the full amount. So we have to both address diversity, equity, and inclusion altogether, or else we don't get the benefits of diversity in solving the big problems that we face as a community. Some DEI experts also argue for adding a B for belonging to the abbreviation DEI. Where do you stand on that concept?
但他们仅仅因为他们是谁而不被允许参与。这对你没有帮助。如果另外两个人可能被允许参与，但就在两分钟前，他们在房间外被质疑是否属于这里，基于他们的身份，他们将无法充分贡献。因此，我们必须同时解决多元、公平和包容问题，否则我们就无法在解决我们作为一个社区所面临的重大问题时获得多元化的好处。一些DEI专家也主张在DEI缩写中增加一个B，代表“归属感”（Belonging）。您对这个概念持什么立场？
Do we need to add the B? I actually think belonging should be an important part of it. But from my perspective, belonging is also a byproduct of feeling like one is included that one has ownership in the enterprise in which they're bringing in. And if one has that sense, then that inclusiveness also tends to lead to a sense of belonging. Let's switch gears for a minute and talk about your research, I mentioned in the introduction that you've spent your career studying racial identity in African Americans. How has the way that psychologists think about racial and ethnic identity
我们需要增加这个B吗？我实际上认为归属感应该是其中的重要组成部分。但从我的角度来看，归属感也是一种副产品，源于感到自己被包容，感到自己对自己所参与的事业拥有所有权。如果一个人有了这种感觉，那么这种包容性往往也会带来一种归属感。让我们换个话题，谈谈您的研究。我在介绍中提到，您职业生涯的大部分时间都在研究非裔美国人的种族认同。心理学家对种族和民族认同的看法，
changed since you began working in the field? Well, first and foremost, more work is actually being done. It's being looked at in a way that it historically had not been. So not only are folks looking at racial identity and African Americans and people of African descent, but now we're looking at racial identity and ethnic identity across a broad group of communities and are focusing much more on the within-group variability or how different African-Americans experience the world and experience race, as opposed to when I first started, much of the work was, how are African-Americans different from whites? And such a binary focus diminishes that focus on the within-group variation. So African-Americans, just like any other community, are rich and vibrant in the sense that they have
在您进入该领域以来发生了怎样的变化？嗯，首先也是最重要的，现在有更多的工作在进行。人们正以一种历史上从未有过的方式审视它。因此，不仅人们在关注非裔美国人和非洲裔人群的种族认同，现在我们还在关注广泛群体中的种族和民族认同，并且更加关注群体内部的差异，或者说不同的非裔美国人如何体验世界和种族。与我刚开始工作时相比，当时大部分工作是研究“非裔美国人与白人有何不同？”这种二元焦点削弱了对群体内部差异的关注。所以，非裔美国人就像任何其他社区一样，是丰富而充满活力的，因为他们拥有
commonalities that almost all African Americans experience. They have things that some African Americans experience and others don't. And they have attitudes, beliefs, experiences that are unique to them as individuals. And one of the most important parts of understanding African Americans and the other groups that have traditionally not been studied is understanding them in the context of their humanity. And the most important part of understanding one's humanity is understanding one's individuality and that there is individual differences and seeing people as being different. One of the fundamental findings that we found in social psychology over the years is that we tend to think about our within groups, the folks that were most close.
几乎所有非裔美国人都经历过的共同点。他们也有一些非裔美国人经历而其他人没有的事情。他们还有作为个体所独有的态度、信念和经历。理解非裔美国人以及其他传统上未被研究的群体的最重要部分之一，是在他们的人性背景下理解他们。而理解一个人的人性的最重要部分，是理解一个人的个性，即存在个体差异，并将人们视为不同的个体。我们在社会心理学中发现的一个基本结论是，多年来，我们倾向于以个人的方式思考我们群体内部的人，即那些与我们最亲近的人，
closest to, especially ourselves, in terms of individuals. And the impact that as individuals, when we do things, we see the humanity there. And we tend to think of other groups as larger groups and seeing their behaviors as being a function of who they are as a larger group. So we may say that, well, women do this because that's how women are. Versus if it's somebody that we actually know, we may say, well, Jan does this because Jan was having a bad day.
尤其是我们自己。当我们作为个体做事时，我们看到了其中的人性。而我们倾向于将其他群体视为更大的群体，并将他们的行为视为他们作为一个大群体身份的体现。所以我们可能会说，嗯，女性这样做是因为女性就是这样。而如果是我们真正认识的人，我们可能会说，嗯，简这样做是因为简今天心情不好。
Or the situation around Jan is more the reason for why Jan may not be smiling, et cetera. And so it's that humanity that looking at within group variation provides that is so important that I think we've made significant strides towards, but still have a ways to go. So it's interesting that there's this need, this fundamental need we have to categorize and to put people in groups. But at the same time, it sounds like you have to resist some of that, not walking in with all these preconceived notions. Absolutely. Absolutely, absolutely. Those preconceived notions often fall into stereotypes that end up having real negative consequences of the life chances of others, as well as limits our ability to connect with people who are different from us. If you are interested in more stories about mental health and well-being, consider on our minds from PBS NewsHour student reporting labs. On Our Minds is a podcast about the teenage experience made by teens for teens.
或者简周围的情况更多是简可能没有微笑的原因，等等。因此，正是这种人性，即审视群体内部的差异，是如此重要。我认为我们已经取得了重大进展，但仍有很长的路要走。所以，我们有一种基本的分类和将人归类的需求，这很有趣。但与此同时，听起来你必须抵制其中的一些，不能带着所有这些先入为主的观念走进去。绝对是这样。绝对，绝对。那些先入为主的观念往往会演变成刻板印象，最终对他人的人生机会产生真正的负面影响，并限制我们与不同于我们的人建立联系的能力。如果你对更多关于心理健康和福祉的故事感兴趣，可以考虑收听PBS新闻一小时学生报道实验室的《On Our Minds》。《On Our Minds》是一档由青少年为青少年制作的关于青少年体验的播客。
Each season is hosted by two teens. This season we're covering topics such as defining success, gender and masculinity, laws affecting teens, music and how it boosts our mood, and more. Student reporters from around the country produce stories. We talk to psychologists, musicians, and authors to get advice. There's a lot on our minds and talking about it helps. On Our Minds, Season 4 is produced by PBS NewsHour Student Reporting Labs in collaboration with KUOW's Radioactive Youth Media. Listen wherever you get your podcasts.
每一季由两名青少年主持。本季我们涵盖的主题包括定义成功、性别与男子气概、影响青少年的法律、音乐及其如何提升我们的情绪等等。来自全国各地的学生记者制作故事。我们采访心理学家、音乐家和作家以获取建议。我们有很多心事，谈论它们会有所帮助。《On Our Minds》第四季由PBS新闻一小时学生报道实验室与KUOW的Radioactive Youth Media合作制作。在任何你获取播客的地方收听。
Now, you're probably best known for developing something called the multimodal model of racial identity, which has been called transformative regarding how people think about racial identity. Can you explain what that model means? Well, so that model really attempts to understand the role that race plays in African-Americans' psychological lives. That in this society, being of African descent, race is such an important characteristic in the society that at some level, African-Americans have to define for themselves what it means in terms of who they are. And for some individuals, that definition is one that is really focused on being race as a significant part of who they are. Whereas for others, it's only a small part of who they are. And for others, still, it's not an important part of how one defines themselves.
现在，您可能最出名的是开发了一种名为“种族认同多模态模型”的东西，它在人们如何思考种族认同方面被称为具有变革性。您能解释一下这个模型意味着什么吗？嗯，这个模型确实试图理解种族在非裔美国人心理生活中所扮演的角色。在这个社会中，作为非洲后裔，种族是一个如此重要的特征，以至于在某种程度上，非裔美国人必须为自己定义它在他们是谁方面的意义。对于一些人来说，这种定义确实将种族视为他们身份的重要组成部分。而对于另一些人来说，它只是他们身份的一小部分。对于还有一些人来说，它并不是一个人定义自己的重要部分。
And so understanding that variation in the significance of race is one of the goals of the model. But along with understanding that variation and the significance that an individual plays on race, we also differ in terms of what we actually think it means to be black, what it means to be a member of our group. We differ in the extent to which we feel very positive about being a member of that group or less positive about being a member of that group. We also differ in terms of the extent to which we think others feel positive towards our group or less positive towards our group. And then a fourth component of this is the way in which we think about our ideologies around what it means to be black.
因此，理解种族重要性的这种差异是该模型的目标之一。但除了理解这种差异以及个人赋予种族的意义之外，我们在对“身为黑人意味着什么”、“作为我们群体的一员意味着什么”的看法上也存在差异。我们对于身为该群体成员感到非常积极或不那么积极的程度也存在差异。我们对于认为他人对我们群体感到积极或不那么积极的程度也存在差异。第四个组成部分是我们思考关于“身为黑人意味着什么”的意识形态的方式。
So some of us may emphasize the commonalities amongst all people. and again, de-emphasize the uniqueness of being black. Others may emphasize the commonalities amongst all black folks when they think about being black, which we would call a nationalist ideology. First, we would call more of a humanist ideology. Some of us focus more in terms of the, larger American experience in the African American term and see themselves as being strongly connected to traditional mainstream American ideas, cultural values, etc. Whereas still others will focus
所以我们中的一些人可能会强调所有人之间的共同点，并再次淡化身为黑人的独特性。其他人可能会在思考身为黑人时强调所有黑人之间的共同点，我们称之为民族主义意识形态。前者我们称之为更具人文主义的意识形态。我们中的一些人更多地关注非裔美国人术语中的更广泛的美国经验，并将自己视为与传统主流美国思想、文化价值观等紧密相连。而另一些人则会关注
on issues of oppression and see commonalities with other oppressed groups. They may differ in terms of who those groups are, but they see a commonality. So if you break down all breakdowns down just the notion of what it means to be black in African Americans, you can see a significant variation in terms of how they psychologically experience one's blackness. And what we found is that that psychological experience of one's blackness has implications for a number of different outcomes when coupled with the different types of racial contexts in which today exist. I mentioned in the introduction that DEI efforts have become a political flashpoint in recent years,
压迫问题，并看到与其他受压迫群体的共同点。他们可能在这些群体是谁方面存在差异，但他们看到了共同点。因此，如果你拆解关于“身为黑人意味着什么”的所有概念，你可以看到非裔美国人在心理上体验其黑人身份的方式存在显著差异。我们发现，这种对黑人身份的心理体验，当与当今存在的不同类型的种族背景相结合时，对许多不同的结果都有影响。我在介绍中提到，DEI工作近年来已成为政治上的引爆点，
and many programs have faced pushback and criticism and even legislative bans, particularly at the state level. As someone who spent your life doing this work, do you feel frustrated by this? And do you think these efforts are still moving even haltingly in a positive direction? I feel incredibly frustrated, and part because the nature of the conversation is often, and the nature of the critique is often at such a surface level and such an uninformed level. So one of the things that I teach my students is that when you begin to have a debate around a set of issues, it's important that you actually define the underlying consequences. that you're attempting to get at. Unfortunately, what's happened is DEI has been defined in ways that have nothing to do with most of the DEI efforts that are at play on our campuses, in our organizations, our corporations.
许多项目面临阻力、批评，甚至在州一级面临立法禁令。作为一生都在从事这项工作的人，您感到沮丧吗？您认为这些努力是否仍在朝着积极的方向发展，即使是步履蹒跚？我感到非常沮丧，部分原因是对话的性质往往如此，批评的性质往往处于如此肤浅和信息匮乏的水平。所以我教学生的一件事是，当你开始围绕一系列问题进行辩论时，重要的是你必须真正定义你试图达到的潜在后果。不幸的是，发生的情况是，DEI被定义的方式与我们校园、组织、企业中大多数正在进行的DEI工作毫无关系。
They have little to do with the actual practices, policies, procedures, procedures that are going on under the idea of DEI. But yet the concept is used as a wedge to create identity threat such that, again, either resources are given or being taken away from one group and given to another small minority group, or there's efforts to try to brainwash people to think in a particular ideology or a particular, usually political ideology, that is, again, seen as a threat to individuals. And people have utilized this, quite frankly, for their own personal, political and professional motives and opportunities to get ahead, when in fact, when you think about what DEI is ultimately about,
它们与以DEI名义进行的实际做法、政策、程序几乎没有关系。然而，这个概念被用作制造身份威胁的楔子，使得资源要么被给予，要么从一个群体被剥夺并给予另一个少数群体，或者存在试图洗脑人们以某种特定意识形态或某种通常是政治意识形态思考的努力，这再次被视为对个人的威胁。人们坦率地说，为了他们自己的个人、政治和职业动机以及获得成功的机会利用了这一点，而事实上，当你思考DEI最终是为了什么时，
most of us would not be outraged by the work that's happening. But one of the criticisms that I often hear about DEI efforts, particularly in business, is that there is not a lot of empirical research demonstrating the value. How do you respond to that assertion? What do you say to the critics who demand show me the numbers? Well, so first of all, I would actually argue there is a great deal of evidence. So there's a great deal of evidence, as I mentioned, that diverse perspectives lead to more creative problem solving, to more ideas, and ultimately more effective ideas. And just about Every business, and I would argue educational case, ultimately comes down to an issue of problem solve.
我们大多数人不会对正在进行的工作感到愤怒。但我经常听到关于DEI工作（特别是在商业领域）的批评之一是，没有多少实证研究证明其价值。您如何回应这种断言？您对那些要求“给我看数据”的批评者怎么说？嗯，首先，我实际上会争辩说有大量的证据。正如我提到的，有大量的证据表明，多元化的视角会带来更具创造性的问题解决、更多的想法，并最终带来更有效的想法。几乎每一项商业案例（我认为教育案例也是如此）最终都归结为问题解决的问题。
And given that diversity is so important to innovation, is so important to creativity, is so important to problem solving. Having a diversity of ideas, a diversity of perspectives is key to just about every industry's mission or goal. And I would argue is key to just about every field in education's mission and goal. I would argue that the sciences are fundamentally about problem solving. The social sciences are fundamentally about problem solving. Most of the professions are fundamentally. about problem solving. And so having that diversity of perspective is incredibly important in that particular space. Now, people will then say, yeah, I'm all for diversity of thought. That's
鉴于多元化对于创新、创造力和问题解决如此重要，拥有多元化的想法、多元化的视角对于几乎每个行业的使命或目标都是关键。我认为对于教育领域中几乎每个学科的使命和目标也是关键。我认为科学从根本上就是关于问题解决的。社会科学从根本上就是关于问题解决的。大多数专业从根本上就是关于问题解决的。因此，拥有那种视角的多元化在那个特定空间中极其重要。现在，人们会说，是的，我完全支持思想的多元化。那
absolutely, in fact, I worry that DEI keeps us from having diversity of thought. Well, the reality is that diversity of thought really comes from a diversity of, lived experiences. That diversity of thought leads to different questions, but those different questions come from individuals' different lived experiences and understanding with regards to how the world works, which we often think of in terms of schemas. I would argue, though, those different experiences about how the world worked are deeply influenced by our various social identities, which again, we have plenty of data to demonstrate. So as a large African-American male who played football, my experience in the world, is very different than someone who is Kim. Very different
绝对是，事实上，我担心DEI阻止了我们拥有思想的多元化。嗯，现实情况是，思想的多元化确实来自于生活经验的多元化。那种思想的多元化导致了不同的问题，但这些不同的问题来自于个人不同的生活经验和对世界如何运作的理解，我们通常称之为图式。不过，我会争辩说，那些关于世界如何运作的不同经验深受我们各种社会身份的影响，这一点我们有大量数据可以证明。作为一个打过橄榄球的高大非裔美国男性，我在世界上的经验与金非常不同。非常不同
from Kim's experiences. And there are things that you would see that I would not see. There are questions that you would ask that I would not ask. And not having that person. not having your perspective in the room damages not only myself, but I mean, not only you, but also damages myself and our larger ability to do good work. So there, and we have the work of Kathy Phillips, the work of Scott Page, so many others have demonstrated the value of diversity with regards to problems. off. Where it becomes a challenge is we often define DEI work as a class or training, and that we assume that DEI training for one day is going to change long-term, historic, societal problems that have happened for generations, and we don't find that actually working. D.E. Do we expect anything different? So DEI is not something that's in a can.
于金的经验。有些事情你会看到，而我不会看到。有些问题你会问，而我不会问。没有那个人，没有你在房间里的视角，不仅损害了我，不仅损害了你，也损害了我，并损害了我们做高质量工作的更大能力。所以，凯西·菲利普斯的工作、斯科特·佩奇的工作，以及许多其他人已经证明了多元化在问题解决方面的价值。挑战在于，我们经常将DEI工作定义为一门课程或培训，并且我们假设为期一天的DEI培训将改变几代人以来长期存在的历史性社会问题，而我们发现这实际上并不奏效。我们期待有什么不同吗？所以DEI不是罐装的东西。
It is not something that is delivered in a single shot. It must fundamentally impact the way in which we as structures, communities, and organizations actually operate. It must change those processes. It must change those procedures. Must change those policies and change those cultures in such a way. that it provides opportunity for a wide variety of experiences and for individuals who are there to feel as if they are both included and that they are not in spaces where they're experiencing
它不是一次性交付的东西。它必须从根本上影响我们作为结构、社区和组织实际运作的方式。它必须改变那些流程。它必须改变那些程序。必须改变那些政策并以某种方式改变那些文化。它为各种各样的经验提供了机会，并让身处其中的个人感到他们既被包容，又不在那些因这种差异而遭受
discrimination and other forms of attack as a function of that difference. I want to turn for a moment to the Supreme Court decision in the case of students for fair admissions versus president and fellows of Harvard College, which found that colleges and universities cannot use race as a factor in admissions. What do you think the impact of that decision will be not only on colleges and universities, but down the road in our society generally? On a personal level, I was deeply disappointed, though I wish I could say surprised. the fact of the matter is race in particular, along with a number of other social identities,
歧视和其他形式攻击的空间里。我想转而谈谈最高法院在“学生公平录取组织诉哈佛学院院长及研究员”一案中的裁决，该裁决发现学院和大学不能将种族作为录取的因素。您认为这一裁决不仅对学院和大学，而且对我们整个社会将产生什么影响？在个人层面上，我深感失望，尽管我希望我能说我感到惊讶。事实是，种族特别是，连同许多其他社会身份，
but race in particular from the founding of this country up until very, very, very, very recently, has fundamentally been a determinant of individuals' life chances. Just simply by being born in a particular racial category, your probability of success, whether it's educational success, whether it's occupational success, whether it's experiencing violence, whether it's experiencing any number of disease, whether it's how long one actually lives, has been fundamentally tied to race. And in many, many, many, many of those instances can also be demonstratively tied to policies that this country has put in place to unlevel, quote unquote, the playing field.
但种族特别是从这个国家的建立直到非常、非常、非常、非常近的时期，从根本上一直是个人生活机会的决定因素。仅仅因为出生在特定的种族类别中，你成功的概率，无论是教育成功、职业成功、经历暴力、经历任何数量的疾病，还是一个人实际活多久，都从根本上与种族挂钩。在许多、许多、许多、许多情况下，也可以证明与这个国家为“不平坦”的竞争环境所制定的政策有关。
And the assumption that by simply saying we are no longer going to look at race as a way to address some of those inequities. And for that matter, not just race, but also gender and national origin, we're also part of the decision is extremely naive and can only make sense from a space of privilege. So it's like you're running a race. And in that race, for the first three quarters of a mile, you put chains on half of the participants and you have them run the race and then you get to a hundred feet from the finish line and you see these disparities there and then say, okay, we're not going to put any more chains on people and say, finish the race. It seems to me to be really misguided, not particularly
而假设仅仅通过说我们不再将种族视为解决其中一些不平等的方法。而且不仅是种族，还有性别和国籍，也是裁决的一部分，这是极其天真的，只能从特权的角度才有意义。这就像你在赛跑。在那场比赛中，在前四分之三英里，你给一半的参赛者戴上锁链，让他们跑完比赛，然后你到达离终点线一百英尺的地方，你看到了这些差异，然后说，好吧，我们不再给人们戴锁链了，说，跑完比赛。在我看来，这真的很误导，并不是特别
well thought out in all of those reasons. So that's my personal experience. Now, with that said, I would argue for my colleagues and having been a chief diversity officer at an institution in a state that had basically already had those same challenges that the Supreme Court put nationally in Michigan, previously in the... 2004, the state passed a constitutional amendment that banned the use of race, gender, and national origin and admissions. And so we have to work very, very hard to find legally permissible ways to address racial, gender, national origin disparities that we all know still exist. And it's going to be incumbent upon those who care about diversity, equity, and inclusion and having a just society to work, to, again, work within the law to find effective ways to address these inequalities. and also to work to find ways to ultimately, hopefully change the law.
深思熟虑。所以这是我的个人经历。话虽如此，我会为我的同事们辩护，并且作为在一个州拥有这些挑战的机构的首席多元化官，最高法院在全国范围内已经在密歇根州实施了同样的挑战。此前在2004年，该州通过了一项宪法修正案，禁止在录取中使用种族、性别和国籍。因此，我们必须非常、非常努力地寻找法律允许的方法来解决我们都知道仍然存在的种族、性别、国籍差异。那些关心多元、公平和包容并拥有一个公正社会的人，将有责任在法律范围内工作，寻找有效的方法来解决这些不平等。并努力寻找最终改变法律的方法。
That's playing the long game. Yeah. On what might be a more positive note, and we can talk about it, is it change? We're seeing in the culture around recognizing the sins of the past, whether that's changing the names of schools and streets to remove the names of enslavers or changing the names of pro sports teams in response to complaints from indigenous people. people, for example. And in the case of APA, we issued a formal apology for policies and practices that denigrated or just ignored people of color over time in the practice and discipline of psychology. How important are these moves? Are they mostly performative or are they truly a step toward infusing DEI into our culture?
那是在下长期的棋。是的。在可能更积极的方面，我们可以谈谈，这是我们在文化中看到的关于承认过去罪恶的变化，无论是为了移除奴隶主的名字而更改学校和街道的名称，还是为了响应原住民的投诉而更改职业运动队的名称。例如，在美国心理学会的案例中，我们发表了一份正式道歉，针对过去在心理学的实践和学科中贬低或仅仅忽视有色人种的政策和做法。这些举措有多重要？它们主要是表演性的，还是它们确实是向将DEI注入我们文化迈出的一步？
That's a very good question. First, I would say they're absolutely performative. And performative is important. So I believe that's an important step. Symbols matter. They're a fundamental part of our culture. And so addressing those performative aspects are important. But they cannot be seen as sufficient in any way. So I see them as necessary, but not sufficient. They have to to be one part of the level of change that has to occur. Part of that change has to always be structural. Part of that change also has to be about redistributing opportunities, redistributing power, redistributing wealth, if one is actually redistributing access and opportunity. These are all part of the change. But if we stop at the
这是一个非常好的问题。首先，我会说它们绝对是表演性的。而表演性很重要。所以我认为这是一个重要的步骤。象征意义很重要。它们是我们文化的基本组成部分。因此，解决那些表演性的方面很重要。但它们在任何方面都不能被视为充分的。所以我认为它们是必要的，但不是充分的。它们必须是必须发生的变革水平的一部分。这种变革的一部分必须始终是结构性的。这种变革的一部分也必须是关于重新分配机会、重新分配权力、重新分配财富，如果一个人实际上是在重新分配获取途径和机会的话。这些都是变革的一部分。但如果我们停留在
performative and say, we did it, then we are dooming ourselves to continue inequality. And that continued inequality not only dooms those of us who are
表演性上，并说，我们做到了，那么我们就是在注定自己继续不平等。而那种持续的不平等不仅注定了我们这些
on the tough end of that, but it also dooms the larger society in terms of being able to actually address the major problems that we face. So I often think, for instance, the cure of cancer, cure to cancer may be sitting in a perspective that a kid in a low-performing school in an intercity space who has a way of asking a very different question just based on what that kid sees every day walking to school that
处于不利地位的人，也注定了更广泛的社会在实际解决我们面临的重大问题方面的能力。所以我经常想，例如，癌症的治愈方法，癌症的治愈方法可能存在于一个在市中心空间表现不佳的学校里的孩子所持有的视角中，他仅仅基于每天上学时所看到的东西，有一种提出非常不同问题的方式，
forces them to ask a question that's just slightly different from the way in which you've always done it in the past that could actually be the cure. But because that kid is stuck in a low-performing school and that will not have an opportunity to connect with our highest performing and our highest resource colleges and universities, they will never have an opportunity to solve that particular problem, or the problem of global warming, or the problem of peace in the world. All of these things that we face as a larger human society
这迫使他们提出一个与你过去一直做的方式略有不同的问题，这实际上可能是治愈方法。但因为那个孩子被困在表现不佳的学校里，将没有机会与我们表现最好和资源最丰富的学院和大学建立联系，他们将永远没有机会解决那个特定的问题，或者全球变暖的问题，或者世界和平的问题。所有这些我们作为一个更广泛的人类社会所面临的事情
is dependent on us having our entire human equity, our human capital in play. And when we allow parts of our society to be systematically excluded from our resources and our opportunities to solve problems, again, not only do they suffer, but we as a larger community also suffer. Last question. I want to circle back to the talk that you gave at the APA Convention. on why diversity matters for psychological science. Why is diversity an especially important issue in psychology and what could and should psychology be doing to address and increase diversity in psychological research? Well, first of all, it is actually relatively simple.
都依赖于我们拥有我们全部的人类公平、我们的人力资本在发挥作用。当我们允许我们社会的某些部分被系统地排除在我们的资源和我们解决问题的机会之外时，再次强调，不仅他们受苦，我们作为一个更大的社区也受苦。最后一个问题。我想回到您在APA年会上发表的关于为什么多元化对心理科学很重要的演讲。为什么多元化在心理学中是一个特别重要的问题，心理学可以而且应该做些什么来解决和增加心理学研究中的多元化？嗯，首先，它实际上相对简单。
So psychology has historically been about studying human behavior. But studying human behavior from an extremely narrow perspective. So studying it primarily in Western, educated, industrial, rich, democratic societies or has been captured weird societies. And even within those very weird societies, the small, small, small slice of the human experience, we tend to, you could say predominantly white, predominantly male, predominantly heterosexual, predominantly able, bodied spaces, and experiences. And as a result, we have a very, very small picture of what normative human behavior actually looks like.
所以心理学在历史上一直致力于研究人类行为。但从一个极其狭窄的视角研究人类行为。所以主要是在西方、受过教育、工业化、富有、民主的社会中研究它，或者被称为WEIRD社会。即使在那些非常WEIRD的社会中，人类经验的一小部分，我们倾向于，你可以说主要是白人、主要是男性、主要是异性恋、主要是身体健全的空间和经验。结果，我们对规范性人类行为实际上是什么样子有一个非常、非常小的图景。
And until we begin to both study. the vast majority of the human experience, include in the folks who are actually doing the study, the vast majority of the human experience, because if you don't, you will risk misinterpreting, misunderstanding what you're actually seeing and doing great harm, which psychology has historically done in many cases. And we have to be willing to accept those new ideas and those new perspectives as enriching our understanding of normative human behavior and not just say, ah, well, he studies African Americans, and that's really nice, that's quaint. But what does that have to do with human behavior, which I have been asked on numerous occasions. throughout my career. And yet we have to change that particular perspective. Does that mean a lot of the science is downright wrong or it's just skewed? I would say a lot of the science, we don't know how much it's skewed because, again, it's important to always remember that when I study African Americans in my work, I'm studying
直到我们开始既研究绝大多数人类经验，又将实际进行研究的人包括在内，即绝大多数人类经验，因为如果你不这样做，你将冒着误解、曲解你实际所见所闻的风险，并造成巨大的伤害，心理学在许多情况下历史上就是这样做的。我们必须愿意接受那些新的想法和那些新的视角，作为丰富我们对规范性人类行为的理解，而不是仅仅说，啊，嗯，他研究非裔美国人，那真的很好，那很古怪。但这与人类行为有什么关系？我在职业生涯中曾多次被问到这个问题。然而，我们必须改变那种特定的视角。这是否意味着很多科学是完全错误的，还是仅仅是偏颇的？我会说很多科学，我们不知道它偏颇到什么程度，因为，再次强调，始终记住，当我在工作中研究非裔美国人时，我是在研究
humans too. So there are certain things about African Americans that are universal to all humans, most likely. And there's certain things about African Americans' experiences that are probably unique to African Americans. And there's certain things that overlap across some African Americans and some non-African American. So we don't really know how limited our psychology actually is, which is even more scary, because we don't really know how limited our psychology actually is, which is, We don't know. And so I think it's especially important for psychology as a science, as a practice, to be as diverse, equitable, and inclusive.
人类。所以关于非裔美国人，有些事情很可能是全人类共有的。关于非裔美国人的经历，有些事情可能是非裔美国人所独有的。有些事情在一些非裔美国人和一些非裔美国人以外的人群中重叠。所以我们并不真正知道我们的心理学实际上有多么局限，这更可怕，因为我们并不真正知道我们的心理学实际上有多么局限，这是，我们不知道。因此，我认为心理学作为一门科学、作为一种实践，尽可能多元、公平和包容尤为重要。
Because we're fundamentally talking about the human experience. Well, Dr. Sellers, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been very interesting talking to you. I appreciate your time. Kim, it has been absolutely my pleasure. I've really enjoyed our conversation. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review.
因为我们从根本上是在谈论人类经验。嗯，塞勒斯博士，我想感谢您今天接受我的采访。与您交谈非常有趣。我很感激您的时间。金，这绝对是我的荣幸。我真的很享受我们的谈话。您可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果您喜欢您所听到的，请给我们留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉。感谢您的收听，我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。